with off canvas instead of stacking
content vertically the off canvas
pattern places less frequently used
content for example navigation or app
menus off screen only showing them if
the screen is large enough on smaller
screens the off canvas content is
typically shown when the user taps on
the hamburger icon let's take a look and
see how it's done on the web fundamental
site in narrow viewports the navigation
menu is hidden until I click the
hamburger menu in other cases the
off-screen content may actually come in
from off the screen in this sample page
the content is coming in from the left
but in other cases it could come in from
the right let's take a look at the code
for this example I have two elements the
dark blue nav and the main content in
light blue in order to make sure the
elements take up the full viewport width
I need to set the width on HTML body and
main to 100% next I'll set the styles
for the off canvas nav element I'll set
a specific width of 300 pixels being
careful to keep it reasonably sized so
it doesn't overflow the viewport I'll
use translate - 300 pixels to move it
off the screen and add a transition of
0.3 seconds so that it animates in
nicely when I want it to appear I'll add
an open class that resets the transform
now I'll add a breakpoint at 600 pixels
that repositions everything back to its
normal spot the media query at 600
pixels resets the transform adding Flex
grow one to the main element allows the
element to grow and take up the full
remaining width of the viewport let's
give it a shot in the browser when the
viewport is small the navigation panel
is hidden until I hit the hamburger menu
but on wider viewport it's shown by
default nice